Alyssa Milano calls on all abortions
supporting women to go on a sex strike
thereby reducing the number of women who
will get abortions in order to own the
pro-lifers or something like that seems
pretty good meanwhile pro-lifers hold a
powerful 1,000 person rally in Philly I
went to it as child stalking
Pennsylvania state Rep Brian Simms hides
in his apartment because for the law
right life is a precious gift whereas
for the left life is a fatal sexually
transmitted disease from which no one
has ever recovered we will talk about
sex baby
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're three days into the sex strike now
all conservative men seem to be doing
pretty great at smiles on their faces
all of the whiny liberal feminist men
who are dating feminist women who are
going on a sex strike seem just as
miserable as they always have so I guess
nothing really has changed we will talk
about sex strikes through the ages from
Aristophanes to Alyssa Milano and why
they don't work but first it is time to
move on to one of our favorite success
stories movement watches founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank they've sold almost 2 million
watches worldwide by bringing quality
designs at fair prices I got to tell you
something I was on a plane the other day
I'm sitting next to a guy wearing a I
won't say the brand very very very
expensive watch the guy looks over at my
watch I'm wearing my movement revolver
Atlas he asks me where I got my watch
from said oh well I can save you 15%
right now actually if you listen to my
show movement watches are all about
looking good while keeping it simple
they don't tell you how many steps
you've taken or they don't blow up your
wrist with stupid text messages they're
not intrusive they don't give you like
beeps and Boop's and all that kind of
stuff they tell the time like a classic
timepiece should do and they look really
good while they're doing it moving the
watches start at just 95 bucks if you
were to try to get this watch in a
department store you'd be paying four or
five hundred bucks for the same quality
from a traditional brand this watch
clean design very minimal it's it's got
this retro vibe to it it reminds me a
lot of watches from the 50s and 60s but
it's updated it's not just a total
throwback it's updated for the modern
era with this clean design and high
quality it's why movement has sold
almost 2 million watches in 160
countries get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t.com slash anoles KO wles
that is movement launching new styles on
their site all the time check it out at
movement MVM t.com / Knowles canna wles
join the movement and get this one the
revolver atlas that's my favorite one so
Alyssa Milano is going on a sex strike
why is she going on a sex strike because
of anti-abortion law
specifically the one passed in Georgia
which says that if a baby has a beating
heart you're not allowed to kill it the
left being led by Hollywood Alyssa
Milano political activists are so upset
that now in Georgia you're not allowed
to kill babies with beating hearts that
they want to go on a sex strike however
like most things that Hollywood
celebrities and leftist activists say
they didn't think this one through this
doesn't make a whole lot of sense Alyssa
Milano wrote quote our reproductive
rights are being erased until women have
legal control over our own bodies we
just cannot risk pregnancy join me by
not having sex until we get bodily
autonomy back I'm calling for a sex
strike pass it on there are no original
ideas on earth this is this is not
original at all this is the premise of
an ancient Greek play called Lysistrata
by Aristophanes so now some people who
are reading about the Alyssa Milano
thing are calling it a Lysistrata so the
premise of that play is that all the men
were fighting in ancient Greece and the
women wanted them to stop going to war
so they all cut them off from sex until
the men would stop going to war this is
a very ancient idea this is a actually a
very conservative idea that the way that
women can affect change in the world is
by withholding sex from men Alyssa
Milano cited how this has been used in
throughout the ages either apocryphally
either just as a matter of telling
stories or in actual history she said
that the Iroquois women refused to have
sex in the 17th century as a way to stop
unregulated warfare so just the same as
the ancient Greek version and she said
very recently Liberian women used a sex
strike in 2003 to demand an end to a
long-running civil war I'm not sure I
was not in Liberia in 2003 so I cannot
verify that however I now may have to
have surgery to remove my mind's eye
because Bette Midler is joining in on
the sex strike so now that image is in
my head and I'm very sorry that image is
in your head is well she tweeted out and
said I hope that women
of Georgia stop having sex with men
until these indignities are overturned
so if you were hoping to sleep with
Bette Midler you're out of luck pal
sorry to tell you that so the thing I
would like to point out about this sex
strike there's so many jokes to be made
about it
the thing I'd like to point out is that
it doesn't make any sense
and it's not just that it doesn't make
any sense in one way or in two ways
there were actually as far as I can tell
seven ways in which the sex strike from
Alyssa Milano does not make any sense
the first one is abortions supporting
women are now practicing chastity
thereby reducing the number of overall
abortions in order to stick it to the
pro-lifers hold on a second there so the
social conservatives who have been
saying for years that women should be
chaste and not be sleeping around with
every guy they see now the pro light of
the pro-abortion women are practicing
chastity they're not going to have sex
and therefore they're not going to have
unwanted pregnancies and therefore
they're going to end abortion cool all
right that's fine if we knew we could do
it that easily we would have not been
campaigning in Georgia and around the
country we would have just called up
Alyssa Milano and tricked her into doing
this sex strike the second way in which
it doesn't make any sense is even let's
say that these pro-abortion women we're
going to have sex and then get pregnant
and then not have abortions even if they
don't have the abortion now the women
who support abortion are going to stop
having sex and therefore stop having
children that they can teach to support
abortion a lot of people inherit their
political views from their parents we
like to think that we're all totally
free thinkers we all completely come to
our own political ideas on our own in
some cases that's certainly true but for
some people they just kind of go along
with the political biases of their
parents in this case the women are not
going to they're not going to have sex
they're not going to have children
they're not going to teach them to
support abortion so over time abortion
activism will die out okay that works
for me again if we don't need the
Georgia law you
we can end abortion another way happy to
do it the next way in which this doesn't
make any sense and this is my favorite
way is just ask yourself if you're
Alyssa Milano or somebody else who does
this hurt not to tell any tales at a
school I don't want to be you know
giving away rumors from the old purple
mattress this does not hurt me this does
not hurt conservative men who ostensibly
are married to or dating or engaged
whatever to women who are not crazy
followers of Alyssa Milano so so the
conservative men still get to have all
the sex they want the men who are
supporting this bill in in Georgia and
other heartbeat bills throughout the
country they're still having all the sex
that they want in this case it's just
leftist women depriving their leftist
boyfriend's of sex in order to stick it
to the Conservatives great great man
this you know I often point out that
feminist men are the creepiest people
that have ever walked the face of the
earth they're all just walking beta or
orcs and they're you you would never let
your your daughter go near a feminist
man feminist men are the kind of guys
who when you go out of town they're
there to comfort your girlfriend you
know that's kind of feminist men so
these guys who have they've basically
made a deal with the devil
they've said we're going to surrender
our manliness we're going to surrender
our masculinity we're gonna we're gonna
not be not be toxic we're gonna be
totally feminist men in order to
ingratiate themselves to women they're
gonna be like really sensitive you know
and mm-hmm
so those guys have made that deal
because they think it's going to help
them sleep with a lot more women and now
those are the only guys who are not
having sex because of this stupid ban
okay works for me
another way in which this doesn't make
sense number four women so the idea is
the only way that women can change this
abortion law in Georgia the only way
they can effect political change is by
not having sex with men and there
for compelling men to change the law
because only men can change the law
except that women make up the majority
of the country and women have a major
voting advantage over men women vote
over men with a 15-point margin so not
only the majority of the country the
majority of the electorate if women want
to affect political change they can now
the premise here of course is ridiculous
Alyssa Milano's premise is that all
women want to have abortion on demand
all the time that isn't true half of
women support pro-life half of women
oppose abortion but if women did all
support abortion you would have you
could change any abortion law in the
country it isn't it's so it's so
ridiculous to say that women are totally
subservient in our body politic women
have the vote women have had the vote
for a hundred years they don't need to
rely on men they don't need to compel
men they don't need to trick men into
giving them what they want to have now
the fifth way in which this doesn't make
any sense is in order to stop men from
controlling women's bodies Alyssa Milano
is going to control women's bodies so in
order to the whole premise here is that
women don't have any autonomy over their
bodies therefore you can't have sex
women and this actually this leads to my
favorite irony of the whole thing which
is that sexually liberated women are now
admitting that men like sex more than
women the Alyssa Milano's of the world
the people who support the sexual
revolution abortion all those sorts of
things they are now admitting that
really men prefer sex and women maybe
they like sex but they don't like it as
much as men sex they say is primarily
about men's pleasure that's the thesis
of the sexual revolution types they
don't they wouldn't admit that in those
words because traditionally sex is
primarily about making babies
I mean a euphemism for sex is hey you're
too gonna go over there and make some
babies that's traditionally but now with
what the abortion activists are saying
is no no sex is not primarily about
making babies we can totally stop making
babies and if you accidentally do make a
baby we'll kill the baby but if it's not
primarily about making babies and what
is it is it primarily about women's
pleasure know if sex were primarily
about women's pleasure then Alyssa
Milano wouldn't propose a sex strike to
compel men to change the law the only
reason the sex strike should work as
because men really really like sex and
women don't like sex that much so now
you've got the left the sexual
revolution types admitting that sex is
primarily about men's pleasure which by
the way in this day and age is obviously
the case and if you talk to any guy
after he's had a couple drinks no matter
if he's a liberal guy a so-called
feminist guy or a regular normal guy
they will all point this out this is the
greatest trick that feminism has ever
played on women is convincing women to
give men limitless sexual gratification
with absolutely no accountability no
responsibility whatsoever and then
convincing themselves that they're the
ones benefiting so women go they'll say
okay I'm gonna go this before so I'm
gonna go and I'm gonna pick up a guy
tonight and we're just gonna have casual
sex and it's not gonna mean anything you
see every guy in the country just oh my
gosh no am I dreaming wake up I'm
pinching myself I can't but the women
have convinced themselves of this
because feminists want to convince women
that women react to sex in exactly the
same way men do and I think a lot of the
reason why some left-wing women are
upset with Alyssa Milano right now is
she's giving away the game she's
admitting no men want sex more than
women do men will like sex physically
more than women do that's why this idea
of a sex strike has existed since the
earliest days of our history it's why
the classic example of this is a play
from ancient Greece and it has persisted
over time now what worse
on the left is a neo Puritanism it's
just a bunch of rules it's like a new
Victorian era the left told us that we
had to get rid of all our old rules
concerning sex right they said no but
you can have sex before you're married
you can have sex outside of marriage you
can have sex with men women animals I
don't know I don't know what they're
saying now you can have threesomes and
foursomes and polyamory and gender
non-binary and 56 genders and no rules
concerning sex that was the pitch in the
1960s and 70s that was the print until
very recently but now once they've
ripped out all the old rules they're the
ones making up a bunch of new rules
they're the ones who on college campuses
around the country are talking about a
sexual assault epidemic title nine on
campus they're calling for consent forms
to have sex consent apps to have sex
redefining the term sexual assault
redefining all these various forms of
sexual assault saying you can only do
this and this and you can only do this
at this time and now Alyssa Milano's
saying women shouldn't have sex at all
until a certain law is repealed how did
this happen how did it go from the
Conservatives making all the rules about
sex and enforcing them to the left
enforcing all the rules about sex it's
because nature abhors a vacuum so I
guess the idea for the nineteen sixties
radicals was when you get rid of
traditional sexual mores then that's it
you'll be fine you just get rid of them
and then we're gonna have an Age of
Aquarius and we're all gonna have a
bunch of hippie-dippie sex and it's
gonna be a lot of fun right that was the
idea of 1968 1969 but inevitably after
that sunny sexy time in the 1960s you
get the 1970s you get the consequences
of that you get the decay and the
degradation and you go from the high of
the drugs in the 60s to the hangover and
the addiction of the 1970s when you get
rid of traditional sexual mores
inevitably you have to invent new ones
why why do we need the rule
because the traditional rules arose for
a reason did you just think I mean I
guess the left thought this did you
think that for thousands of years of
human history we've had fairly similar
rules governing sex I mean some changes
over time we've always had a lot of
rules concerning sex did you think that
we had all of those rules just cuz just
by accident because a bunch of old
people weren't as enlightened as you and
now you're so enlightened so you realize
we don't need any rules about sex it was
just an accident thousands of years of
human history
no we the rules arose because you need
rules about sex because sex poses
serious questions and sex poses serious
problems that you have to seriously
confront so fine you in the 1960s you
want to get rid of all the old rules
concerning sex sex before marriage
prophylactics it was a condoms the pill
things like that abortion you have the
major abortion debates in the 60s
ultimately leading to roe v-- wade in
the 70s you totally changed the rules
even down to that essential rule that
you shouldn't kill a baby abortion was
such a shame such a disgrace as late as
the 1950s 60s 70s now all of a sudden of
shout your abortion you have people
proud of their abortions they're not
really proud but they're pretending to
be proud of their abortions you totally
changed the rules okay there's no no
more rules not no bars everything's okay
nothing is wrong if it feels good do it
and then what happens if someone gets
sexually assaulted
oh hey we're just having fun there's no
more rules if there's no rules can you
can you force someone to have sex
against her will no obvious okay so you
need a rule there well how do you know
that she's consenting what if she's had
a few drinks you're the one encouraging
everyone to go out and get blackout
drunk and go to go to bars and parties
all the time so what if she does that
what if she's not blackout drunk but she
just has casual sex
she regrets it the next day because the
guy just walks out and leaves her is
that there's no rules there's no
accountability there's no traditional
sexual mores that okay no that's that's
kind of wrong too isn't it what if now
you go out you have sex you produce a
baby and the baby's growing and and you
want to kill it can you are you allowed
to kill that baby
that seems a bridge too far what is that
that is what we're litigating right now
the rules will reinstate themselves
nature abhors a vacuum the big
difference here is the worldview for the
left life is a sexually transmitted
disease it is fatal and no one has ever
survived it this is why they call
abortion reproductive health they use
this euphemism reproductive health and
it's ironic because abortion is not
about reproduction it's about the
opposite of reproduction it's about
stopping reproduction but they call it
reproductive health because for the left
to ban abortion is the same thing as
banning a treatment for chlamydia to ban
abortion is the same thing as banning a
treatment for gonorrhea or herpes it's a
sexually transmitted disease it's a it's
a bad consequence of sex is pregnancy
according to the left it's it's a it's
an STD to treat rather than have the
right views it which is that it's a
sexually generated gift and what this
argument comes down to is what is life
not this stupid argument that some
people have in abortion debates where
they say well when does life begin how
can you prove that life begins at
conception the word conception that's
how I can prove it life begins at
conception by definition in conception
you have a sperm cell has 23 chromosomes
it's a sperm cell it'll just if you
leave it be it'll just be a sperm cell
and eventually it'll die then you have
an egg also has 23 chromosomes and if
you leave it be it'll just be an egg and
then it'll die and then when you combine
them when the sperm fertilizes the egg
at the moment of conception it becomes a
human being with 46 chromosomes usually
sometimes the differences but 46
chromosomes a new individual human being
with individual human DNA that is
developing in a perfectly continuous
path into a little tiny baby and then a
bigger baby and then a toddler and then
a child and then a preteen and then a
teenager then an adult then a senior
citizen and then then they die it's this
spoiler that story but that is that is a
total path of life undisturbed
continuous from the very beginning it's
we're not asking the question when does
life begin that's obvious at the moment
of conception you've got something that
is a living it meets all of the
scientific characteristics of life
scientists have described the
characteristics of life over the years
the unborn baby meets all of those it's
obviously human it's not a giraffe it's
not a zebra it's not a little dog that's
a human being it's genetically human it
is Hume it is essentially human it's
independent it's not part of the mother
it is distinct from the mother we're not
arguing about when that life begins were
arguing about what life is how life
should be treated is life a burden is
life awful is life terrible sometimes
today you hear environmentalists say we
can't bring more children into the world
it's bad for the earth if you bring in
more children it will it will increase
the effects of global warming sometimes
you hear people make the same argument
for the opposite reason they say we
can't bring more children into the world
because the world is so bad and it's too
bad for children so hold on I thought
the children were too bad for the world
no the world is too bad for children
according to some people there's so much
crime there's so much suffering life
essentially is evil according to these
people life is a bad thing and it's got
to be cured and the cure that they've
come up with on the pro-abortion left
the Alyssa
Milano left the Democratic Party left is
to kill it in the womb very different
from what we saw in Philadelphia I was
in Philly last Friday over with my pal
Matt Walsh because Matt decided to throw
a pro-life demonstration outside of that
Planned Parenthood where Brian Sims that
state representative was bullying
elderly women bullying underage girls
trying to docs them Matt said on a
Tuesday said we should have a rally here
then
Lyle arose live-action came out they
said we're gonna get a permit we're
gonna do the rally three days later
there's a major rally in Philly over a
thousand people according to CBS News
that's according to a left-wing news
source they're saying it was over a
thousand people I was there was I
couldn't tell how many people there were
because there were just so many as far
as the eye could see we got some video
we talked to some people on the street
there were a handful of pro-abortion
demonstrators we talked to them we
talked to a lot of the pro-life people
we will discuss this major difference in
world view and then we will talk about a
Ock OC just admitted that one of her
major arguments for the green new deal
is a total joke then if we have time
we'll talk about our latest presidential
candidate nickname Alfred E Newman for
mr. Pete Buddha judge what Pete worried
all of that and more but first you got
to go to Daly wire.com ten bucks a month
$100 for annual membership you get me
you get the end of our Clavin show you
get the Ben Shapiro show you get the
Matt Walsh show you get to ask questions
in the mailbag coming up on Thursday you
get to ask questions backstage also
coming up you get another Kingdom and
you get this the leftist tears tumblr oh
this is a special concoction mm-hmm this
is that sweet georgia brew some of that
sweet tea left us tears mmm tastes
really good tastes like you can't kill
babies after six weeks go get yours we
got more of these bills coming across
the nation go to daily wire calm we'll
be right back
this pro-life demonstration in Philly
outside of that Planned Parenthood is
one of the most powerful events I've
ever attended I had never been to a
major pro-life rally like this I'd never
been to a Planned Parenthood I'm sure
I've walked by them I've just haven't
noticed it Planned Parenthood is
ghoulish man it is a chilling place to
walk by it is chilling to the bone it is
chilling to look at those activists it's
chilling to look at the building and to
know what happens in there before this
rally even started I got there an hour
early and I was hanging around with Matt
and Lyle and some of the other people
who were putting the event together
before it started there were hundreds of
people there and some of them were
political activists some of them were
politicians some of them were just there
praying and this is what really struck
me is you look at sort of concentric
circles from the main event stage and
you see people giving impassioned
speeches about the science of it I
talked to a biology teacher there who
was there just talking about the biology
of abortion and you see some politicians
political activists political candidates
then you see just religious people
priests nuns just quietly saying the
Rosary to themselves I could have cried
I've really almost cried on the spot
because you realize it's all real
sometimes when you talk about these
political issues things that become
hotly debated in politics they become
abstract to you abortion rights 36 weeks
26 weeks six weeks heartbeat bill they
become abstractions and then you look in
that building and you know that there
are real people in there killing real
babies then you look at the faces of
people who were just praying quietly and
you realize they're really praying for
real babies and real mothers Planned
Parenthood has staffers and they have
volunteers who are called patient
escorts and the theory here the line
that they want you to believe
is they have patient escorts because of
those awful and intimidating pro-life
activists yelling awful things that the
women does not happen does not happen at
all I was there there were a thousand
pro-life advocates there there was a
sign that said pray for Brian Simms
there were people quietly praying there
were signs that said have courage mom
nobody yelling no hatred no none of that
that's a total lie from Planned
Parenthood the reason that Planned
Parenthood has patient escorts out there
is not to protect women who are going to
have abortions from the awful evil slurs
of pro-lifers it's to protect women from
their own conscience it's to protect
women from getting information about
adoption how in the United States there
are 36 couples waiting to adopt everyone
baby that is born and put up for
adoption
it's Planned Parenthood trying to
protect their customer base because they
know that if women are allowed to have
this information women are allowed to
see the earnest faces of people praying
they're never going to go into that
awful place and let those awful people
kill her child so they have to protect
their customer base or their money's
going to run out their customers are
going to run their industry is going to
run out they're not going to be able to
sell the dismembered babies for a profit
which we know that they do we caught
them on video joking about it laughing
about it total exposure was a total
exposure here the way you can look at
there was a woman who walked into
Planned Parenthood just before our our
rally started and the look on her face
was of she was distraught so I don't
think she was going in to get a breast
exam and I don't think she was going in
to get a pack of condoms
she looked distraught nobody from the
pro-life rally was yelling at her nobody
was saying anything to her they were
praying for her they weren't and you had
that you had that awful Planned
Parenthood patient as
pushing her in come on lady get in there
get in there and make sure we kill that
baby and you had this woman looking
distraught nobody ever looks happy going
into a Planned Parenthood
nobody's ever skipping along joyfully as
they walk into a Planned Parenthood
tells you everything the left is so
insistent go do it this is hard but go
do you have to do it you don't have to
do it there was no reason to get an
abortion to kill your child nobody looks
happy walking in there that the Planned
Parenthood staffers and volunteers don't
look happy you know who looked happy and
joyful the pro-lifers praying and
demonstrating in front of it singing
song singing god Bless America giving
speeches about basic science praying
there was one couple I talked to out
there there were only maybe half a dozen
pro-abortion protestors virtually none
of them would talk to me one couple did
they had a sign that said I voted for
Brian Simms and so I asked the guy said
you have a sign it says I vote for Brian
Simms what's that about do you regret
that here's what he said so I see your
sign says I vote for Brian said we voted
for years did you see that and
unfortunately we've gotten into this
very very dark time where we believe
that women's rights outweigh the right
of the body growing inside of them we
need more rights not less so we need we
read up we need health care we don't
need our health care taken away and part
it out is abortion rights you would
agree abortions not health care for the
baby who's killed
[Music]
what do you don't know if it's not a
baby than what is it he wants to know he
wants a biology lesson I don't need a
biology lesson I don't think I'm the one
who needs a biology lesson even the
language he uses gives away the whole
story
he says the baby is not a baby well then
why'd you call it a baby a thing can't
be can't not be the thing that it is if
it's not a baby what is it he can't
answer of course he can't answer there's
no argument it's that so they have no
argument they have a lot of emotion they
have a lot of slogans and then you ask
them the subtlest any question about
their slogans they collapse it is that
simple Matt who organized this whole
thing he put it beautifully here's just
a little clip of his speech I'm sure
he'll talk about it more on his show
today but here's just a great little
clip from his his major speech at the
rally now there are two fundamental
messages that we want to get across
today I think secondarily we are sending
a message to bullies like Brian Simms
and then message is very simple that we
will not be intimidated we will not be
silenced so Brian maybe now you
understand something but if you try to
shut us up we're only going to get
louder and if you if you try to shame us
we're only going to stand taller
and if you try to scare us we're only
gonna get bolder that's the way this
works and I'll tell you the reason for
that it's because we know that our cause
is just we know that we are right we are
firm in that truth
we have truth on our side and we will
wield it like a sword to defend the
unborn now Brian I know why you use
scare tactics I know why you bully why
you try to intimidate because that's all
you have you have no arguments to
present you have no case to make you
have only chest thumping and schoolyard
taunts well they're not going to work
it's not good enough that's it that's
exactly it
they have no argument I went there I
flew from Missouri up to Philly because
Brian Sims said he wanted to talk to pro
lifers he was going out on the street
harassing little girls and elderly women
and I thought okay Brian Sims can pick
on somebody his own size if he wants to
talk to pro-life advocates guess where
he was hiding he there's no way he was
showing up we were right there in his
neighborhood right on his block he
wouldn't come out now he's blocked his
Twitter page he's locked his Twitter
accounts so that I can't say other
people can't see his page that's it and
it's a great message for pro-lifers
great message for conservatives
generally it seems sometimes like
challenges are insurmountable if I when
I was a kid if you told me that we would
be on the verge of limiting abortion
pushing abortion all the way back to the
fringes if not overturning roe v wade
entirely I would have laughed at you I
said what are you talking about the
Supreme Court ruled on it twice more
than that the whole culture is for
abortion there's no way that could
possibly happen and now look where we
are
they the left does this the left always
inflates their numbers they do it
because they have the mainstream media
they do it because they have the
universities and they do it cuz they
censor anybody who has an alternative
point of view but once you get past that
facade once you get past that
smoke-and-mirrors you realize they're
nothing it's like The Wizard of Oz you
see the big scary guy in the screen and
you see it's a little guy standing
behind
curtain when you when you confront them
when you show up to that Planned
Parenthood when you could show up to
Brian and sims's neighborhood they all
disappear those Planned Parenthood
activists are not allowed to speak to
pro lifers lest they hear some truth
lest they dialogue with people who do
have an argument you when you finally
confront these bullies when you finally
confront these people you find out
they're nothing they fold like a house
of cards speaking of having no argument
before we go we got to turn our
attention to Washington DC because one
of the major arguments that the left has
used to dominate our discourse over the
last two months
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez saw him at the
green New Deal she said that the world
was gonna end in 12 years because of
global warming she just came out and
said it was just a joke she came out she
remember this is her big argument the
world's over in ten years some
presidential candidates bethe or work
said it's going to end in ten years
they're trying to out left win one
another now she came and said oh hahaha
I was only kidding she tweeted out quote
this is a technique of the GOP to take
dry humor and sarcasm literally and
fact-check it like the world ending in
12 years thing you'd have to have the
social intelligence of a sea sponge to
think it's literal but the GOP is
basically Dwight from the office so who
knows hahaha
first of all if a OC is really going to
bring up fact-checking obvious humor as
an example of some stupidity let's not
forget that Snopes fact check all these
things are constantly fact-checking the
babble on be there fact-checking obvious
satirical websites as though they were
drew this is talk about the pot calling
the kettle black but let's take a Oh see
at her word AOC is saying guys guys I
was totally just kidding about the green
New Deal and about the world ending in
12 years from global warming what why on
earth could you possibly take me
seriously well here's how she said it
let me know if you think this is a joke
the part of it that is generational is
that Millennials and people have you
know Gen Z and all these folks that come
after us are looking up and we're like
the world is going to end in 12 years if
we don't address climate change and your
biggest issue is your your biggest issue
is how are we gonna pay for it and like
this is the war this is our world war
two does it look like she's joking there
to you she's at an event called MLK now
and she's talking to Tommy Z Coates one
of the most self-serious left-wing
writers and she says the world is going
to end in 12 years if we don't stop
global warming and then that whole
audience there you'll notice they didn't
laugh right what did they do they
applauded it and cheered but they didn't
laugh because it wasn't a joke she
didn't laugh as she was saying you cut
you see the image of Tommy he's e-codes
he's not laughing sure doesn't sound
like a joke but maybe I don't know maybe
it is here's another video this one's a
little more casual of aoc talking about
the world ending imminently we're
screwed
oh I'm sorry to break it to you if we do
nothing there is no hope
period when it comes to climate in
particular we're actually screwed there
is a global threat to the planet a
global threat and at this point we don't
even have to prove it just walk outside
in winter in a lot of places and it's
either way worse than you're used to or
way warmer than you're used to
hurricanes storms wildfires we are dying
now there's scientific consensus that
the lives of children are gonna be very
difficult and it does lead I think young
people to have a legitimate question you
know should is it okay to still have
children oh there it is
there is that thing that we talked about
at the top of the show
AOC was the first one to call for a sex
strike I guess there's that thing that
the left does they say don't have
children because it's bad for the
environment or don't have children
because the environments bad for the
children or don't have children it's
children are bad in and of themselves
they just don't want you to have
children so she calls for that she says
maybe maybe we shouldn't have any more
kids
then look if the only evidence of her
talking about how the world is about to
end because of global warming for this
video I would say maybe she was kidding
because it's actually a hilarious video
but I think it's unintentionally
hilarious I don't think she's trying to
be funny I think she just kind of is
funny we're laughing at her and not
laughing with her she says that this is
a global threat to the planet not just a
regular threat but a global threat to
the planet with which we might want to
point out to her most threats to the
planet are global there are very few
threats to the planet that are not
global because the planet is a globe but
she says we can see it happening now we
can see we don't even need to show
evidence for good you just see if it's
hot outside that's evidence of global
warming and by the way if it's cold
outside that is also evidence of global
warming see there's evidence everywhere
anything that happens is evidence to
prove my theory and this one does seem
ridiculous but if you think that she's
joking
because of how ridiculous she looks just
watch what she goes on to say just
listen to this we have 12 years left to
cut emissions by at least 50%
if not more you may laugh but your
grandkids will not I think she kind of
forget she actually says later in the
video
she says the Internet is forever and
history is going to judge you Yeah right
IOC the Internet is forever so now that
you're saying that the 12 years line was
a joke we can go back to I don't know a
month or two ago when you said that if
anybody says the 12 years line is a joke
there are awful people
and their grandchildren are gonna judge
them and hate them for it she explicitly
said not two months ago that if you
question the world ending in 12 years
because of global warming and you call
it a joke you're a terrible person and
then what did she do today she said that
the 12 years line that the world is
gonna end in 12 years cause of global
warming is a joke there is a joke in all
of this there is a joke the joke has
about three letters in her name three
letters in her initial thought like a
million letters in her name
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes that is the
joke speaking of politician jokes I
can't leave without addressing one of
the funniest lines of the presidential
race so far President Trump was asked
about the candidacy of South Bend
Indiana mayor Pete Budaj and his
response was quote Alfred Newman cannot
be the President of the United States
and when I read that I burst out
laughing because the reference is to
Alfred E Newman who is the goofy face on
the cover of Mad Magazine and I love Mad
Magazine I read it a ton when I was a
kid I subscribed for years so I thought
it was hilarious
however putas jej had a really good
response to this that I think he
responded in about the best way he could
have come today in an interview compared
you to be Mad Magazine mascot said
Alfred Newman can never be president
what's your response so I'll be honest I
had to google that I guess it's a
generational thing I didn't get the
reference it's kind of funny I guess but
he's also the President of the United
States and I'm surprised he's not
spending more time trying to salvage
this China deal a very strong response
from Budaj edge because he's right it is
a dated reference I know that Mad
Magazine is still in print I really like
Mad Magazine
it is a dated reference I bet if you
asked most Millennials who Alfred E
Newman is they probably wouldn't know
and so so what Budaj edge does is he
says ha ha see Trump is old and I'm
young and he's the past and I'm the
future so you should vote for me
okay fair enough Trump is a pop culture
guys so if he's only making dated
references that's probably not too great
right
except that Trump is the President of
the United States anything he says
automatically becomes basically the
biggest news story in the world we're
talking about it everybody's talking
about it
this dominated the news cycles on the
left and the right for a few days after
he said it which means that now
everybody gets the reference so you've
got okay you've got a dated reference
that is hilarious because Pete Buddha
judge does look like Alfred E Newman
maybe some people didn't get it before
but now that from said it everybody gets
it
which is why it's a good attack which is
why I think it's gonna stick because
it's also so specific so comedy really
thrives in specificity
you've a things aren't that funny but
when you really really drill down to two
hardcore specifics if Trump had said
yeah Pete Buddha judge isn't gonna win
cuz he looks like a cartoon character
that's kind of a lame joke that's not
that funny PFP Buddha judge isn't gonna
win because he looks kind of goofy
that's not a great joke he says yeah
Buddha judge can't win because Alfred E
Newman will never be the President of
the United States that is it funny line
because it's very specific it were calls
a highly visual image and a
long-standing image and it's true that's
the other thing about comedy is it has
to be true so he nailed it he made the
comparison I hadn't seen anybody make it
before although said Gorkha pointed out
to me that he had actually made this
comparison a few weeks ago so it clearly
said has excellent insight here but I
think it sticks I think it's a good line
and the way that Trump will try to spin
Buddha judges response is that he's this
arrogant kid who doesn't know much about
history and and I think the way he'll
try to spin it is the way Reagan spun
attacks on his age in the 1984 campaign
there was that famous clip where his
opponent brought up where Mondale
brought up that Reagan was so old and
this should cause us to question his
ability to be President and Reagan
famously said
I will not make age an issue in this
campaign I will not exploit for
political purposes my opponents youth
and inexperience and it was a fabulous
response and Mondale said that was the
moment when he knew that Reagan had won
the election and so I think Trump will
probably spin it that way I think in
terms of the hits on the age it's
probably going to be a draw and now as
always happens with the king of
marketing you've got this brutal image
when you think Budaj edge you now think
the goofy guy from the cover of Mad
Magazine you Google Buddha judge Alfred
e Neumann comes up you google Alfred
Newman Buddha judge comes up I think it
in the end Trump landed the punch and
it's gonna hurt him not that Buddha
judges I I think a really serious
presidential candidate but he might be a
serious VP candidate and Trump landed
the blow all right we'll talk more
tomorrow about the guy that Budaj edge
is totally replacing bado or orc
remember him I don't I don't really
remember him either
we'll get to that tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy Borah
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today feminists have apparently
discovered the value of abstinence you
never thought it would happen but it did
they're going on a sex strike to protest
some of the pro-life laws that have been
passed across the country personally I
think it's a great idea I support it
100% and I'll talk about why also a
democratic congresswoman has landed in
some hot water because she yet again
said something horrific and totally
bizarre but yet again she is of course
the victim because people are quoting
her verbatim that's the pattern here and
finally someone emailed me with an
interesting question they want to know
are there contradictions in the Bible I
will do my best to address that question
as well today over on the Matt Walsh
show